CLOSE THEIR METHOD WITH THE
FOLLOWING, "THIS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING."
AND UP NEXT, BOY, HOW MUCH DID
THE SMOLLETT CASE COST THE CITY
OF CHICAGO?
NOT JUST MONETARILY, BUT
RESOURCES THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER SERVED OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY?
TOTAL COST OF MAN-HOURS
COMMITTED WILL NOT COME OUT
UNLESS SMOLLETT IS ACTUALLY
CHARGED, WE ARE TOLD THEY WENT
WELL BEYOND WHAT A COMPARABLE
INVESTIGATION OF THIS SORT WOULD
REQUIRE, NORMALLY.
WHAT ABOUT THE ACTUAL CRIME
COMMITTED SINCE SMOLLETT MADE
HIS CLAIM?
THESE ARE THE STATS THE POLICE
SHARED WITH US TODAY.
FROM GENERA 28, THE DAY BEFORE
THE ALLEGED SMOLLETT INCIDENT,
THROUGH FIBER 17TH, CHICAGO
REPORTED 22 MURDERS, 134
INSTANCES OF CRIMINAL
SEXUAL ASSAULT, THREADED 42
ROBBERIES, 88 INSTANCES OF
AGGRAVATED BATTERY.
WHAT ABOUT THE BACKLOG OF
UNSOLVED MURDERS IN THE CITY?
BACK IN 2000, THE CITY SOUGHT
41% OF MURDERS THAT OCCURRED
THAT YEAR.
IN 2009, ONLY 30% OF MURDERS
WERE SOLVED.
BY 2017, JUST A 17% OF MURDERS
THEY HAVE TO FOCUS ALL OF THEIR
RESOURCES ON FIXING THAT.
JOINING US NOW IS SOMEONE WITH
INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF THAT
FORCE, FORMER CHICAGO OFFICER
DIMITRI ROBERTS.
DIMITRI, WHAT IS THE FEELING
AMONG THE CHICAGO PD, DO YOU
THINK, NOW, WITH EVERYTHING THAT
HAS HAPPENED?
ALL THE MAN-HOURS TAKEN AWAY?
>> I CAN TELL YOU, SOMEONE WHO
IS BENT ON THE STREETS MANY A
NIGHT AND WORKED SIMILAR CASES,
IT IS FRUSTRATING WHEN YOU HAVE
A SITUATION LIKE THIS WHERE, AT
A MINIMUM, YOU WOULD EXPECT THE
VICTIM TO COOPERATE FULLY AND
WILLINGLY IN SUCH A HIGH-PROFILE
CASE, ONE HAS BROUGHT NATIONAL
MEDIA ATTENTION.
AND THAT IS JUST NOT HAPPENING.
THE OFFICERS I'VE SPOKE WITH ARE
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED WITH WHAT
IS GOING ON, BUT MORE SO AS WE
TALK ABOUT ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS,
IT IS TAKING CRITICAL RESOURCES
OFF THE STREETS.
>> Laura: WE ARE TOLD HE IS
NOT COOPERATING WITH POLICE.
HIS LAWYER IS LIKE, HE IS BEING
VICTIMIZED BY THESE ALLEGATIONS
ALL OVER AGAIN, KIND OF BLAMING
THE POLICE.
HE IS NOT GOING TO TALK.
HOW DO THEY GET HIM TO TALK?
ARE YOU GOING TO SUBPOENA HIM?
>> I MEAN, IT DEPENDS, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE GOING TO
WASTE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WITH
GOING THROUGH SUBPOENAS AND THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS TO GET HIM TO
TALK FURTHER.
ABOUT WHAT OBVIOUSLY, AT THIS
POINT, SEEMS TO BE SOME FALSE
STATEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE.
>> Laura: YOU THINK?
>> AND EVENTS WE HAVE ALREADY
UNCOVERED TO BE UNTRUE.
I DON'T KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO
WASTE MY PRECIOUS RESOURCES --
>> Laura: GRAND JURY CHARGE
HIM FOR A FELONY OR NOTHING?
>> THEY COULD DO THAT, BUT IN
MOST CASES, THE BACKLOG OF
INCIDENTS IN CHICAGO, THIS WILL
UNFORTUNATELY FALL BY THE
WAYSIDE OUT OF THE NEW CYCLE.
NOT SOMETHING I AGREE WITH, BUT
THE FACT OF WHAT IS PROBABLY
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Laura: THAT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT LOOK AT ALL OF THE UNSOLVED
MURDERS.
THE PEOPLE GOING TO KEEP DOING
THESE FAKE HOAXES IF THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH IT?
IF THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH WHAT
HE SEEMS TO HAVE DONE HERE?
WOW.
>> I THINK THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
TO BRING ATTENTION TO THESE
THINGS.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THEM IN
THE NATIONAL MEDIA, AND WE
REALLY HAVE TO SHED LIGHT ON
SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
TAKING SUCH EGREGIOUS CRIMES
LIKE HATE CRIMES, A VERY HEATED
POLITICAL CLIMATE IN THIS
COUNTRY, BRINGING ISSUES AND
TAKING AWAY ADVOCACY AROUND
THINGS THAT SHOULD BE ADVOCATED.
>> Laura: CARTY BEYOND
INSTAGRAM, SHE SAID I DON'T WANT
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSET
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEE
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEY
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSES
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEP
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEL
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEC
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEE
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEI
TO COMPLETELY BLAME HIM BECAUSEN
CHICAGO ARE RACIST.
THAT GENIUS, CARDI B, AS THEY
MIGHT TRY TO FRAME HIM AND LOOK
LIKE HE IS A LIAR.
AS THE CHICAGO PD RACIST,
DIMITRI?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I SERVED MY COMMUNITY VERY WELL,
AND MOST OF THE OFFICERS ARE
DOING THE SAME THING.
I'M NOT SAYING THERE AREN'T SOME
BAD APPLES, BUT I THINK CARDI B
IS SPEAKING A LITTLE OUT OF
IGNORANCE, AND SHE NEEDS TO GIVE
MORE CREDIT TO THE OFFICERS THAT